ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo videoooo!!
Oggi parliamo di depilazione
in particolare delle ragazze quando si depilano
sono sicura che ognuno di voi si ritroverà in almeno una di queste tipologie e quindi buona visione ci vediamo alla fine del video
sono in alto mare ma tu raccontami tutto. COSAA!
Ma stai scherzando,e non mi dici niente
Sono troppo contenta. certo però mi immaginavo che comunque eh capito?
Tranquilli che arriva anche da voi,non la passerete liscia
l'avevo detto io
non ce la faccio,coraggio maryna, uno,due,tre..
Ma tutto qui pensavo peggio
Marco ciao che sorpresa una festa in piscina
Certo che ci sono sì sì sì sì.fra 15 minuti? no è perfetto va benissimo a dopo
speriamo che ci siano. da qualche parte dovranno pur essere no? ma dove li ho messi?
si! grazie!
Perfetta sono pronta per la festa in piscina
Dame tu cosita uh uh
dame tu cosita uh uh
amo ho troppa paura e se sbaglio qualcosa . amo ma stai scherzando?
è la mia prima volta ce sto in ansia
guarda che è facilissimo usare le strisce
mi aiuti? ovvio
amo mi sa che non ci vado all'appuntamento con marco. per quale motivo scusa?
non gli piacerò mai.
ma se ti ha chiesto lui di uscire
si ma sono grassa
ma cosa stai dicendo
Guarda che doppie punte che ho. ma secondo te ti va a guardare le doppie punte?
sì ma ho anche 2000 peli
bhe in effetti un po di peli li hai ma per questo c'è una soluzione quindi adesso tu vai in bagno ti depili
ti trucchi,ti fai bella e poi vai a quell'appuntamento
fila
Sorriso
uno
due
tre
quattro
cinque,sei e sette,apposto.
possiamo uscire
Allora adesso
andiamo a controllare che sicuramente sarà rimasto qualche pelo piccolo e indifeso
che mi è sfuggito
non vedo niente
li ho tolti tutti,incredibile
no vabe,adoro
amo cosa sono questi peli? tu pensi veramente di passare l'estate con i pantaloni?
effettivamente sembro un po un orso. ma giusto un pochino.
aspettami qua
allora facciamo così, io la faccio a te e  tu la fai a me pensa che  amica che sono
allora vai
Ok
Dimmi quando ci sei. vai uno,due,tre.
Adoro
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del video come al solito fatemi sapere lasciandomi un commentino qui sotto a quale di queste tipologie appartenete con l'hashtag
corrispondente per esempio a #latattica,#lamultitasking eccetera eccetera
se volete acquistare le strisce depilatorie che ho utilizzato nel video vi lascio qui sotto in descrizione il link allo store di amazon
se questa è la prima volta che vedete un mio video
ricordatevi di iscrivervi subito al mio canale e di cliccare la campanella che trovate vicino al tasto di iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti I nuovi video e soprattutto per essere I primi a commentare e soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram e musically, io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al prossimo video
adoro ciao